Even now at nighttime, you
can see the destruction
caused by
what Ukrainian officials say
was a Russian missile
that hit these two nine story apartment
buildings around
midday here in separation
killing, Ukrainian authorities
say at least one person
and wounding at least 32 more.
Now, this city is located
just about a half hour's drive
from active front lines,
and it has been pummeled in the past
by Russian missiles and rockets
that have hit apartment buildings here
with deadly results.
These buildings
kind of face towards the southwest
and that is
in the direction of Russian occupied
Ukrainian territory.
So you can kind of come to the conclusion
that this
deadly projectile
would have flown from that direction.
We can here at night now
under cover of darkness.
Some residents
in some of the neighboring apartments
that have been
badly damaged, working in the dark,
cleaning up rubble and shards of glass
in what's left of their homes.
Missile
hits here
and my apartment is this kitchen,
my parents room and my room.
When it happened,
I heard a loud explosion.
I saw a fire and I covered my head
partially and on a chair.
And they're taking me up
to their apartment.
There right next to
I mean, they're
part of the same building
that was hit today,
the Russian modules here.
The manager who's here, there's a crater
right next door
in the side of the building.
Bible says this does not scare him.
Please give us more weapons.
Imagine how terrifying,
how absolutely shocking
it would have been
if you were at home
when this massive explosion took place,
blowing in all the windows
of the kitchen.
And then to see
just less than a stone's throw away,
a huge crater
in the side of your neighbor's building.
And it leaves me with this question
What possible
strategic military goal
could there be to fire deadly
long range missiles at people's homes?
And Ivan's joining
us now live from the war zone.
Ivan, on a day of deadly strikes
by the Russians,
the Ukrainian president
Zelensky sent a powerful message.
What can you tell us about that?
He traveled to this southeastern
Ukrainian city of Mahmoud,
which has been for months now
the scene of this deadly grudge match
between the Ukrainian
and Russian militaries,
where Ukrainian
forces have been holding out,
defending repeated Russian assaults.
He met with injured soldiers.
He handed out awards.
He denounced the the air strike.
The missile
strike ends up Russia
and on a different
town in the Kiev Oblast
that killed at least eight people.
And he stopped at one of these
convenience stores
that are all over this country
and drank coffee with Ukrainian troops
who took selfies with him.
He's a courageous leader indeed.
All right.
Ivan Watson, thank you very much.
Stay safe over there.
Joining us now to discuss
what's going on, CNN contributor
and Russian Affair's Jill Dougherty
and CNN military analyst, retired Colonel
Cedric Leighton.
Jill,
how revealing
are these deadly Russian strikes
on civilian targets
so soon after Putin
and the visiting Chinese president
Xi Jinping tried to portray themselves
as working for peace in Ukraine.
Yeah, I mean, that's the irony of it.
And obviously,
President Putin is saying
full steam
ahead, this is not going to stop.
I mean,
if you look at the negotiated
discussions that she and Putin had,
they didn't really get into
any specifics.
They were generalities about peace.
And certainly President
Xi wants to look like a peacekeeper.
But in actual fact,
I don't think it accomplished
much of anything.
Most of the discussions
were really about economics.
And for Russia, that's
the most important thing. And for China.
So sadly,
I think this is just Putin saying
we are going to proceed
just the way we have.
And, you know, the same brutality
that we're seeing all over the country,
you know, the day
after the Chinese leader leaves.
You see what the Russians
are still up to.
Colonel Leighton,
what does it do for Ukrainian morale
to see President Zelensky on the ground
right near the front lines,
honoring the fighters of Mahmoud?
Yeah, it's a huge boost, Wolf,
when the president himself
comes to see the troops
at the front line.
And it's really ironic,
you know, when you compare Zelensky
visiting his troops
basically in broad daylight
and mingling with them,
handing out awards,
doing the things that he needs
to do to boost morale.
And you compare that to Putin's visit
to Mariupol.
Night and day contrast, literally.
Retired Colonel Cedric Leighton,
thank you very much.
Jill Dougherty, thanks to you as well.